yes we must [ __ ] hey yo hey yo what
up Brandon what a deal love the [ __ ]
podcast I got a debate club for you in
over face what's the better movies Al
Pacino
Robert De Niro both legends both are
classics but who has the best collection
of movies you turn the gang signs
Brownsville Texas gang [ __ ] your Spanish
on point
buzz buzz game game you wall Papa
gracias thank you well there's no chess
my baby thank you very much our amigo
where we appreciate you sending this in
from there from Brownsville from the
border bro y'all hold it down over there
oh yeah
that's a good question I'm going to Nero
man that's Al Pacino what you know then
yeah De Niro got to political for me I'm
going Pacino here's the other problem
with Robert De Niro he was [ __ ]
crashing it when he was younger and then
all of a sudden he it's this girlfriend
right and she wants all this [ __ ] so
then he has to keep making these shitty
movies so hit he started towards the end
of his career started making [ __ ] movies
dude being the dad of the grandpa and
everything you know I'm saying yeah dude
the Irishman is pretty I mean it's like
it's bad it's almost like a book well my
problem is they look like avatars
like the the the makeup dude just hire
young actors yeah
just hire yeah I like the digital [ __ ]
well it's just like now some of these
movies and I do respond it's like when
somebody gets into their prime it's like
if they almost make a movie we just get
to look at them for two hours you know
and look at him for three hours yeah
dude that was so good
I'll go Pacino who was in taxi driver
that was Pacino housing hero De Niro Wow
raging raging bull' De Niro keep De Niro
and Al Pacino
to meet the parents that's my Goodfellas
Robert De Niro
Casino Robert De Niro hmm makes it real
tough and what some Pacino ones ah sound
MEAC out of all them scarf there are
fathers Godfather's
ah Carlito's Way Oh Serpico
Serpico you know where's the cop yeah
i'ma stay uh-uh I love that movie with
the Bob who just a pervert dude some
Blancas blundering around
do I like Al Pacino on Jack and Jill
with Adam Sandler - I like that movie -
yeah Robert Dino's a [ __ ]
he's a mom yeah I mean look there's a
lot of great options out there
Godfather's oh those were so great he
well they're both in I know yeah
what are some other movies Robert didn't
Robert there's some big boys though
casino Goodfellas Goodfellas the intern
I'm just naming always he's got some
rough ones get some rubbers nothing babe
pig in the city he was there he was the
city was it he was a fish and shark
still he was a fish a shark so if he did
the comedian yeah oh he's a joker bro oh
yeah blast in the face boy alert let
movies been out for so long a dirty
grandpa mmm Bennett's him down Hillary
grandpa oh he's on Saturday Night Live
three times dirty grandpa tough that's
an L the intern grudge match like I said
he made some real for you [ __ ] Vegas
dude he made some [ __ ] movies and he got
caught yelling at his girlfriend in a
restaurant because of it okay I just
like to make no [ __ ] movies he said yeah
and he only dates black girls you know
that oh oh yeah big point for Robert
didn't it yes you know that I'd not know
that oh he likes the black point that's
a huge point I'm with them 15 minutes
men of honor
okay let's get over down Patino then man
this is too many movies this guy's done
he can't be good if he does that many
I'm super political no to write it's all
put a little weird now I like when he
cuts on scene any older please like I
would like that older people get
political they always do well there's
nothing else to do is there now Pacino
is definitely held up better I think
dude Dick Tracy Wow oh dude hold up dude
Willie Beamen you're gonna go out there
every inch we waited by that in --see
fight on it oh my god what was that
do you remember any given sundown oh
we've all time what's once upon a time
in Hollywood you didn't like it like it
what was it it's kind of I guess a
documentary of Charles Manson narrated
by tina.bill worst who I ever heard that
oh I loved it Ocean's thirteen he was
after 13 just good my hair like that uh
for the money Angels in America Gigli
oh yeah that's a knock against any given
Sunday dude - for the money
devil Chinese coffee he was in some bad
[ __ ] Donnie Brasco I know without Pacino
for the win
are you you know what I'm a very rich
scent of a woman really did it for me
man do I wish we could play that we
fight for that inch yeah we get them on
the run we're gonna keep them on the run
gonna go go go go go go go where I can
stop I'm gonna stop we get going dr.
Rudy across that goal line they don't
keep going - getting across the goal I'm
just travelling around the city with the
ball Rudy's offsides I stand by that 63%
DeNiro Wow that's all right a lot of
people want to get ales today they boy
here's a plate of ales for all y'all
Al's up hos Al's up
back up my broccolini
get your life together touch me bro I'm
not touching